This is a seasonal anime video.
Where's the anime?
*BOOM* There's your anime.
What season?
Spring season.
*BOOM*
Cherry blossoms.
It's like, the start of every fuckin' highschool anime now!
Am I going to be covering your favorite anime this season?
maybe...
maybe not.
But what I can guarantee, is that I will disappoint you as much as you disappoint your own parents.
(hi dad)
And of course, last thing we need is some beats up in here,
so what perfect music shouts out both anime and spring?
Thats right, we were all thinking it,
Phil Collins!
sorry, i just
really felt like putting
phil collins in here for absolutely no reason
We start off with some good ol' fashion fujobait.
and you know its GOOD fujobait when one of the guys
actually looks almost fuckable if they only gave him a pair of tits.
you
didnt hear me say that out...
loud...
Now they DO have a tsundere in the first episode,
but... it IS a guy,
so obviously it doesn't... appeal... to me...
cuz wh-wha-what do i look like?
a guy ju- just
d-do i look like a ts- tsundegay?
*gags* *laughter*
THAT WASNT EVEN ON THE SCRIPT
I JUST MADE UP JUST NOW
Following up DavidProduction's hugely successful Diamond is Unbreakable,
is Sagarada Reset.
Alright, it isn't exactly Part 5,
but imagine a town where the world's shittiest stand users
gather around and discuss philosophy.
Our protagonist this time has the AMAZING POWER of a pretty good memory,
Granting the supernatural ability of being able to remember where he puts his keys.
He meets a girl with the ability to reset time, but not remember any of it,
with the added ability of having a personality of a soggy biscuit.
Together, the team up and form,
the Dustcloth Crusaders!
this is what part 5 died for
Honestly,  I saw the name "Clockwork Planet",
and I genuinely wondered what the show could be about,
only to find out within the first minute, that it's about a planet...
...made out of clockworks.
...i dont know what i was expecting.
On the other hand though, I have to genuinely wonder
who thought making a planet out of CLOCKWORK would be a practical idea.
}
The original Shingeki no Bahamut was a good show,
and this looks like a good sequel
of a good show
with a good OP(ening) and
good animation.
yeah its...
its...
its pretty good!
Kinda like Saekano,
"How to Raise a Boring Girlfriend"
which was also a good self aware harem show
that I haven't quite finished the first season yet
so why don't we just all dance around this ball of adequate goodness
that ALL these sequels are giving us?
Eromanga-sensei is one of those shows
you;ve probably seen alot of random images and .gifs floating around alot,
but what is it actually about?
Well, for those of you who are unaware,
It's a long-awaited patch to Oreimo.
Now I know this may just look like a basic re-skin,
I mean, it still has the same otaku-incest bait premise
that drew us in initially,
and the maps DO look very similar.
But if you check the offical patch notes here,
you can see that it isn't just a re-skin.
There are some balance changes with the waifus
and made some of them more desirable this time,
but the BIGGEST changes, you can see is how people
were unhappy, having to pick between Team Kirino and Kuroneko,
so what they DID was just kind of combine the two of them
into one character.
Which many people are saying it's gonna make her pretty OP,
especially with the Incest Buff, but in my opinion,
it's still too early to tell at the moment.
They DID however make all the characters 12 years old lolis,
a controversial move, I know,
but I suspect that's to do with the preparation they're making
for the new Chris Hansen gamemode they're developing.
Seriously, though.
This show is absolute trash, and so is anyone who likes it.
s-so does anyone want to join me in this trash bag?
BUT WHAT CAN I SAY IM HAVING A GOOD TIME
Though... you know...
i also enjoyed kind of enjoyed oreimo
including season two
and the ending
(hello?)
((is anyone still here?))
(((anyone?)))
Oh, wow...
I can't wait for the episode where they reveal to us that
Boruto is Naruto and Sasuke's kid~
all along~
Let's be real here.
We all expected Boruto to suck.
REALLY suck.
It was milking a franchise that was ready and waiting to die.
So it REALLY has no right being this enjoyable.
It has the perfect balance of nostalgia for those of us who grew up with the characters,
but feels fresh and new enough that it's like re-experiencing
why we liked the series to begin with.
It's like we've been seeing this beloved dead horse
being beaten for about 5 years now,
and just when we're all ready to let it go,
they give one last beating,
except out of nowhere,
the horse gets up and starts running.
This time it's not just a horse
IT'S A MAJESTIC FUCKING UNICORN
FLYING OVER THE RAINBOW
AND IT IS GLORIOUS.
Now we can just wait for that unicorn to fly into 10 seasons of filler
and start the cycle of disappointment all over again.
Oh shit, it's uhh...
UUUHHH...
((what's the name of this show again?))
I'm just kidding! It's Attack on Titan!
who
who fuckin' knew?
Now I know it has only been a quick
since the hype train had it's pitstop,
but I genuinely like the direction this season has taken.
The horror-mystery aspect feels like a nice change of pace.
Titans are genuinely terrifying again,
andwerenotputtingallthefocusonsomelittle punk-ass bi
The OP(ening) is not as good,
but of course, not because nothing will ever match the first one,
also, can we PLEASE talk about this?
Actually, let's not.
Look, the bottom line is that we only have 12 episodes,
so will we finally find out what is in Eren's basement?!
probably fuckin' not.
so it's a good thing you can find out what's in the basement
by reading ahead in the manga on a site like BookWalker.
((WO-OAH OH SHIT IS THAT A MOTHERFUCKING SEGWAY?))
OOOOH, you know what time it is!
BookWalker is Kadokawa's official e-book store
where you can buy and read manga and light novels,
online or on your app on mobile devices!
((I was told to emphasize that this is an e-book store,
as people don't know what that means in this day and age..?))
I was actually really impressed with their selections
considering everything here is 100% legal and official.
So even if you're about to comment
that you have already read ahead in the manga for Attack on Titan,
((you swarmy git))
From this season, they also have the
manga and light novels of Saekano and Danmachi,
but they also have some other fan favorites like
KONOSUBA,
Spice and Wolf,
Haruhi,
((and Baccano)),
But if you use Coupon Code: [Gigguk] to get
$5 off your first purchase!
It'll support the industry,
it will help me out for every one of you who does,
and you get a free volume, so it's win win!
just use the fucking code, links are in the description
Alright, so I know alot of the comments are going to be mentioning
the abundance of sequels we're getting this season.
And ya know, I get it.
It's a sequel heavy season, and your favorite anime
PROBABLY hasn't gotten one announced yet,
or you just want something original.
Buuut, you know there was obviously enough backing
to get these shows another season,
So we should just be happy for the fans
that back these shows!
So yeah, I'm not going to rag on any particular sequel for getting approved,
BUT HOW THE ACTUAL FUCK?!
has every author literally stopped giving a shit about their light novel names now?
Alright, I fully admit it
I really didn't want to give this one a chance
because it's a light novel adaptation,
of a fantasy setting,
with a stupid fuck-off name.
So, if it ends up being great,
I'm sure you will all be here telling me how wrong I am.
And hey, while you're at it,
why not throw Granblue Fantasy in there too?
And I guess Re:Creators too,
as we have yet another loser nerd,
being sucked into a fantasy world.
Errrrrrrghhhgh
wait a minute, is that a giant robot?
And, did she just summon a tommygun
and use a sword to play it like a violin as a weapon?!
AND WAIT
ISN'T THIS HIROYUKI SAWANO?!
AND- WHAT THE F-
IS THAT GATE OF BABYLON WITH ROCKET LAUNC-
((GUYS,
I DONT KNOW KNOW WHATS GOING ON,
BUT I THINK I JUST CAME))
Alright, so this was balls-to-the-walls awesome
and I'm not sure why more people weren't talking about this.
I mean, instead of a guy being transported into a fantasy world,
how about fantasy world being transported into a guy?
WITH GIANT ROBOTS
AND ROCKET LAUNCHERS
WHAT WHATEVER THE FUCK THIS ATTACK IS
The only thing that could've made this first episode better
was if we had the Sawano Drop.
You know the one I mean,
that one song in every Sawano OST that's just like
So judging from the cover,
what I expected from this show was a
feelgood-slice of life about a wise old man bonding with a young girl.
What I DIDN'T expect was a wise old man bonding with a young girl
WHO IS ACTUALLY A ELFEN LIED STYLE LABRAT ESCAPEE.
BEING CHASED BY A MYSTERIOUS ORGANIZATION
and crappy cg
AGAINST OTHER ADORABLE LABRATS.
While the old man is just... there,
teaching life lessons.
Seriously, this old man is the best thing about this show,
because there's all these anime tropes being
thrown around in the story and he's just like
"I don't have time for this stupid anime shit!"
Honestly, we should all just go to Japan
and adopt a grumpy elderly Japanese man
to teach us life lessons,
because I honestly can't think of anything more I need.
So you know that moment when you graduate from college,
you're in mountains of debt
and it's impossible to get an entry level job
no matter how many interviews you go through?
that wasnt
a joke.
P.A Works are back at it again with a show
about young working women...
working.
Yep! It's not Cute Girls doing Cute Things,
but Working Women doing Working Things!
But instead of a "let's-look-at-the-anime-industry",
this time, it's a charming tale of a city girl
getting a job in a rural town,
where everyone is friendly
and we have adorable elderly japanese men!
seriously, someone get me my own elderly japanese grandpa right now
So I'm sure anyone who took a quick look at the
title of this show and the studio it came from,
could easily assume that this has something to do with Re:Zero.
I mean,
just look at the fuckin' title and they're both fantasy shows as well.
But I assure you, this has absolutely nothing to do
with Re:Zero at all.
They are NOT connected,
and any such connections are only just in your head.
AAAAAAND
I think that's pretty much everything
worth mentioning this season.
Again, thank you to BookWalker for collaborating with me
with the vouchers this month,
so make sure you use Coupon Code: GIGGUK while you still have the chance!
Cause it has been a pretty good season!
A nice mix of new,
and sequels,
and ya know,
I mean, we have Attack on Titan, so...
I mean, who can...
Hold on a second.
aren't I forgetting something important..?
♫Easy Lover by Philip Bailey and Phil Collins starts playing♫
We interrupt this broadcast to bring you in an important message:
TOOOURNAMENT AAAAARCC
Okuyasu: TOOOOOURNAMENTTT
AAAAAAAAARCCC
Mikasa: Tournament Arc?
TOOOOOOURNAMENT AAAAAARCC
nah i dont think i missed anything.